[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about Justin's fate in the final
season out getting terms this video
includes season 8 footage leaks and
leaked photos are spoiling John's path
through his final episodes that's why
the title includes confirmed spoilers so
you've been warned
beside leaks in this video you'll also
hear a few theories and predictions
about just now in season 8 okay let's
just jump into it in first episode of
the final season we'll see Jon Snow
arriving home at Winterfell as the long
night comes bearing down on Westeros Jon
Snow and Danny are heading north to
prepare for the great war with their
crews arrival at Winterfell pretty much
all the main characters will be at the
same place at the same time and it only
makes sense for some of them to finally
reunite and share a couple of words when
John arrives at Winterfell he'll have a
heartbreaking reunion with his family
with sin sari and bran as well as with
his friend Sam and his Darvill ghost
firstly Jon sensor Union has been
confirmed to take place in the season 8
premiere with the season 8 first look
teaser image we got to see a clip of
January night amid sister and Lady of
Winterfell Sansa some of the fans
claimed the hug share doesn't feel all
that warm and we should worry about
senses attentions some are even going
that far to claim that this clip rematch
incensed as possible betrayal over Jon
Snow this my opinion is not the case has
already had an opportunity told 12 jon
in season 7 that the northern Lords were
complaining that the king in the north
should have stayed in the north with
Lord Glover and Lord Royce even going
that far to propose Sansa to take power
in the absence of her brother Jon if she
wanted to sensible that already betrayed
Jon instead she insisted that jon is
their true ruler with doing what he
believes is right for their people and
that she is merely his regent so
sensible change our theory in my opinion
is not plausible at all the reason why
censor may be glaring over Jon shoulder
turned out to be Danny just as we here
on fire and blood expected and there
will be some tension between sense and
Jon's new lover having in mind that
sense of back in the second episode of
the seventh season said that Danny
doesn't want to help the north but
rather wants to conquer it it's fair to
assume that sense of and not accept
Danny as well as Jon did or at least not
at first
as Danny said herself in the season 7
finale she's not hearing nor
to conquer it but rather to save it and
it's something the north Lords will see
for themselves in a very beginning of
the final season sensible see for
yourself who tential is and what her
true intentions are and eventually truly
accept her and they will get along since
I might also stay to both John and Danny
they're risking their lives and losing
one of three dragons in order to protic
windsor said that the army of the dead
israel was both stupid and pointless mo
as we say losing one dragon Circe will
never help her own enemies in war no
matter it's against the night King this
is something censor knows because out of
all of them she's the one who spend the
most time with Cersei and she's the only
one who fully understand that search
they would never provide a living savage
troops that she's likely to lose in the
great war and therefore weaken our
position on the Iron Throne as the queen
of the Seven Kingdoms since I will also
warn Danny that Cersei will take
advantage of the war between the living
and the dead which serves to confirm
itself in the season 7 finale that's a
side of sense I'm looking for and hoping
to see in the final season anyways it's
not only John and Sansa who will finally
Reno item in our file it's also John and
Arya the most anticipated game
appearance reigning you'll be made into
scissoring in between those two since
the very first season will be hoping for
Jon Arryn in season 7 but it will just
miss each other however they will
finally reunite in the first episode
john loves and cares for all his
siblings but John and Arya have a unique
bond which the show made sure to remind
us of just before the actual reading
takes place with Sansa mentioning to
Arya how happy John will be when his
Cesar Artie will be out of NFL at the
moment of John and Dana's arrival she'll
be at winter town among the small folk
but they will still reunite in a season
8 premiere and this is that exact moment
in the godswood domino fell this rain
will definitely be heartbreaking John an
REO were very close growing up it was
John who secretly head needle forged for
Arya encouraging her to become who she
always wanted to be a warrior it's only
fitting for them to see each other again
before the great war begins I cannot
wait to see these two fighting together
in his net king's army John Italian
still sword then are a bit Valyrian
steel dagger jonald arena with brain as
well it's been a long time since John
seen bran but brain did see John in
season 4 when he was travelling north of
the wall he saw John from afar fighting
the mutineers too many Lord Commander
brain is beside Sam and Howland Reed the
only person who knows
Shalini agent who witnessed John's birth
even though he has been waiting the
whole season to reveal to John the truth
I don't think he will reveal to John in
their first meeting
the reason being too many people around
them Brennan central likely wait for a
private moment with John rather than
revealing such an important
life-changing information to him in
front of everyone and I think wait bran
might not even be the one to reveal the
truth him an actor who plays Sam tease
this about his character in season 8
same is really filling the
responsibilities of this information but
he knows John would rather hear this
from Sam than anybody else
is this a confirmation that same will be
the one to reveal John the truth or did
he say that just to throw away your
aside Sam and brain discovered together
the truth but Sam would probably be a
better messenger given brains detachment
from his family and weird behavior ever
since he became the three-eyed Raven an
actor who plays Brent is this about his
character we see a slightly wiser brand
is here who's less like robot overload
that's great to hear
still the two will probably agree that
it's battery Sen delivers this breaking
news to Jon and thus cliff seems to be
that exact moment and imagine upon
arriving in Winterfell beside reuniting
this family General Serena's friend Sam
who also knows the truth behind his true
lineage John and Sam will see each other
for the very first time since Janice
killed and resurrected Sam might even be
the one to reveal to Johnny true
parentage while Holland could confirm
these same statements to John with some
evidence if John tells them about what
happened to him in the Nights Watch
death and resurrection
it's possible they decided revealing to
John that he's a Targaryen semi-tight
also proclaimed genres were high in the
season 7 premiere show pointing out that
the bow Gilly picked up and began
reading was a book about the long night
while the exact part she was reading was
about the prophecy of azor Ahai I
already made a video regarding which
character might be this prophesied
Savior but John's son of Ice and Fire
since more and more to be the Lord shows
it anyways upon finding out about John's
shoe parentage in season 7 which basic
confirms that he is a Song of Ice and
Fire
and upon finding out about John's death
and resurrection the final season it's
quite possible at Samuel proclaim John
as were high hero that was reborn amid
smokin salt a hero that will build the
flaming sword to stand against the
others and if he falls the world falls
better it's going to be very interesting
to see John's reaction
like his father Rhaegar I think general
eventually accept his part in the
prophecy and in a Great War that's all
I'm going to say about it for now I also
believe that the book about the long
night that Gilley was reading in season
7 premiere will resurface in the final
season which would likely lead Sam -
once again as bran if he is able to look
back in time but his time even deeper in
the past to see what exactly happened
the last time the White Walkers came for
the living this is how salmon brain will
play a huge role in the final season as
they will help John and Danny strategize
for their fight against the night King
and his army of the Dead this whole
problem well quite a few flashbacks
where we learn a bit more about why
Walker scenario motivations now the jack
has reunited with his family and friends
he has one more important reunion to
face the one with his direwolf it's been
confirmed that ghost will finally return
in season eight all of us enjoyed the
dragons but their walls have also been a
huge part of gaming Jones especially of
the stark children we have not seen
ghost ever since Jon's resurrection for
all of you wondering where Ghost even is
he's a winner fell the showrunners
confirmed that ghost a demeanor fell
it's and Sam and John left to meet Danny
a Dragonstone during season seven
instead of goes the showrunners decided
to fulfill their long-awaited wish of
having an undead bear for the final
season however the game matures
production has much higher budget and
ghost will finally be back at it John
will arena if it goes early on in the
season then I'm sure we'll see more of
him in the following episodes especially
in the battle for Winterfell that is
taking place in Episode three if you
look closely on the official trailer you
could even notice ghosts in the
background in case you missed it pay
attention to the left or Jorah moment
when the camera pans on his hardened
Bell ready face and he'll notice
something that's out of focus something
white and are well shaped moving around
in the background
it's definitely ghost in my opinion in
there somewhere is Jon Snow as well
however while there will be a few
moments of heartbreaking reunions
between John his family and friends
there will be no time for much small
talk because Winterfell is already
preparing for the war Beneful now has a
dark trench around it and everyone
wields regulus weapons and shields even
though John is done aware of the fact
that the night king and his army are
marching south of the wall Bren already
informed everyone in Winterfell as he
himself through his folk of ramus
witness the moment with the night king
destroyed a large portion of the wall
allowing his army to march south
upon being informed about this huge news
next thing we will see Manor
fellas is it was soon-to-be John having
an urgent meeting the majority of the
Norton Lords and his allies at the Great
Hall in order to discuss their strategy
and defenses jungle somewhere in the mid
season learned of his show lineage
better to say more brain or maybe even
through Howland Reed once John learns
he's a Targaryen which basically means
he and Danny are related this Rhaegar is
his father and Danny's Rhaegar sister
the irony so Helen then is carrying his
child
it is behind by the numerous times
during the season that Dany believes she
can no longer have children because of a
prophecy that was told her by Miriam us
during the season 1 finale the prophecy
tells and the Sun rises in the West and
sets in the east when the Seas go dry
and the mountains blow in the wind like
leaves when your womb quickens again and
you bear a living child then he will
return and not before
even though Danny does believe in this
prophecy as John pointed out himself it
may not be entirely true
additionally so many people were talking
about the in his ability to help
children in so many scenes that it seems
like John and Danny having a baby is not
even questionable
I was rather foreshadowed there and
talked to Danny about her plan for
succession Danny talked with John our
dragons are the only children she'll
ever have and even draw talk to John
about John's future child just as John
stated it's highly possible that the
witch was not being honest today which
along with all those foreshadows might
mean that the season finale brings more
surprises than we hoped for
if Danny truly is pregnant that
definitely something John will find out
earlier in the season the only problem
is Danny getting pregnant is another
theory that's been floating around for
quite some time if then it surely got
pregnant casita and childbirth we know
that her own mother died giving birth to
her John's mother also died giving birth
to him which puts Dan in dangerous
situation how I see John learning this
is through Danny of course and probably
the crypts of NFL will John the real
today any issue parentage or not is also
something that interests me I think this
might take place as early as episode 2
of the final season it was revealed that
episode 2 will see the return of the
crypts of NFL which was being filmed on
its long-standing location at Shane's
castle it was also reported there will
be a scene between two leading cast
members in crypts and they will be
discussing Ned Stark's death in this
particular scene so it's basically
something similar to what we already saw
in season seven sense and airy disc
snails death as well as the statue my
guess is that this time it will be John
and Danny discussing it and it might be
before or after Danny reveals to John
that she's pregnant with his child since
its episode two one episode before the
nanking arrives at Manor foul it's
highly possible that this is the episode
in which Holland appears to these troops
and supports the north in the living and
also tells John the truth what we also
know about this episode though seen is
that it ends with a horn being blown as
you know in the Nights Watch a horn is
blown to warn of someone approaching it
arrangers returning Wildings to the
gates or White Walkers in my opinion is
definitely White Walkers and the same
will be the end of episode 2 if you have
been following my own season a new scent
leaked photos you know that there is a
big battle set to take place in season 8
and it's been confirmed to take place in
the third episode of the final season
but the actor who plays the night king
Vladimir verdict
even though venom fell will not be the
first Castle to be destroyed on his path
he will arrival there by the 3rd episode
which is when this epic battle for
Winterfell begins verdict let the news
slip during a fan convention Hungary he
stood as Poland third episode of the
last season there's a battle that the
creator's intended to be historic moment
in television almost the full episode
will be about battle it will take about
one hour we don't have many Johnston
leaks from episode 3 but I guess we
don't really need them the night king is
attacking Winterfell John defense
Winterfell all I hope is that John
fights alongside ghost in area and ghost
doesn't actually end up sacrificing
himself for John someone pick this up
from the new teaser here looks like John
bears a Targaryen pin similar to Danny's
during the battle from ven FL I'm not
sure what we do know however is that
winter will not fall at Winterfell it's
better it'll be a huge defeat for the
living Winterfell is on fire the nat
king is gone but don't worry
Jon Snow and most main characters will
survive as you might expect this battle
will leave many dead check out this
image of corpses strewn across the
ground outside the VFL set and money
glass which is just one of a bunch so
just arrives the most dangerous place to
be in episode 3 the place I tell you by
vine hundred thousand strong army of the
Dead led by the night king and then in
Episode four goes to the second most
dangerous place for him place ruled by
Cersei Lannister Johnston will return to
King's Landing in episode 4 for the
first time in the history of the series
target Harrington's film shooting
something in Dubrovnik meaning that John
is headed back to King's Landing at some
point in season eight and since director
of episode four was seen on set we can
say for a fact that this will take place
in Episode four in this photo Harrington
is at the brahmic Smith's at a tower
which is part of the city walls sir st.
John snow meet one on one in King's
Landing
well not exactly one on one a Cersei has
her Queen's Guard in the mountain around
her is John coming to play with Cersei
and once again answer to provide him
with troops or Jean trying to come in
sir said to let them all in
to make their final stand in King's
Landing there are many possibilities
however before John goes to King's
Landing he will go to dragonstone meet
Danny a new teaser also provided this
shot of Dana standing in front of a
fireplace with your back turned to John
looking into details they figured out
this must be from episode 4 because
there are not that many fell here there
is Dragonstone now we know that the
living will retreat to Dragonstone after
Winterfell falls take a look at the
fireplace probs the stone curves and the
metalwork it's the same thing we already
saw a dragon stone so now we know
they'll retreat to check on stone after
manna fell false
looks like John and Danny will have a
tense conversation after losing the
battle for Venna fell and since they are
a gemstone this clip is likely from
episode 4 and it's a post-fight moment
but also seemingly opposed Joshua
parentage reveal moment as well finally
new teasers also answer the question to
the biggest Jon Snow question going into
season 8 will John ride the dragon yes
and here's the reaction of Aries Davos
and Tyrion seeing it these three have
already seen dragons above their heads
quite a lot of times so the only reason
they would look at the dragon with a bit
of shark would be seeing just on writing
daily Saturday Rago a joker named after
John's father Rhaegar Targaryen in the
trailer we see John and Danny
approaching ryokan in regal and here
they're probably applying them above in
FL so we pretty much know everything
regarding John's fate in the first four
episodes of the final season in episode
1 he will reunited his family then in
episode 2 he'll find out his true
parentage from Sam and he'll most likely
also learn of Danny's pregnancy in
episode 2 general probably ride a dragon
in episode 3 he will fight for
Winterfell
but after its fall skill retreat with
others to Dragonstone in episode 4 but
he will not stay there for long
as leaked photos confirmed that he will
also be at King's Landing in the same
episode there here guys everything we
know about Justin's fate in season 8 and
I have to admit it's a lot sure we do
not know John's endgame yet but we
pretty much know everything else I hope
you like it and please let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace